[Music]
How long are you going to stay?
[Music] I'd like to
change my clothes. Please,
if you want to watch this, you
can stay here.
Oh, I'd appreciate it
if you could refrain from looking at me like that.
I
used to be a peeping hobby.Now,
after the princess who has no common sense, she's pestering a dragon at a national event.Now she's a peeping girl.What
kind of character are you planning to make me into?I do
n't want her to get swept up in all this [ __ ], but what if I
show up then?  He was spying on me while I was sleeping.
[Music] That
wasn't my hobby, it
was just a misunderstanding. I apologized for that, right? And you
saw that I said no. He
attacked me while I was sleeping in my bed.
That time when I cried like it was the end of the world because I thought it was the end of the world.No matter when I
cried, you were the one who did the thing that made me misunderstand in the first place.I'm sorry,
Noah also apologized, right?